[Musique]
nous sommes heureux de vous accueillir à
l'université d'evry
donc aujourd'hui l'université d'evry
accueille le premier événement donc que
l'on a fait sur la corde et mutualisé
paris saclay d'accorder paris 7 les a
démarré le 4 novembre
chacun avait des formats un peu
différent il a on a décidé de lancer
cette expérience ensemble le 21 janvier
dans le cadre de la semaine nationale
des cordées de la réussite
donc cette année une journée de
formation et métiers donc l'objectif
c'est de rassembler des jeunes qui sont
tutoré dans différents établissements
l'université d'evry mais aussi
polytechnique hec agroparistech et ils
vont pouvoir soit assister à des
conférences qui vont présenter l'iut
l'université les écoles d'ingénieurs de
commerce ou alors rencontrer des
professionnels qui vont leur parler de
leur métier
l'un des professionnels du secteur de la
logistique des ressources humaines
un vétérinaire nous avons aussi un
journaliste et donc ça va permettre
effectivement de découvrir tous ces
éléments-là poser des questions dans des
cadres pour les rendez-vous métiers qui
sont relativement informel et puis ce
qui me paraît important c'est aussi
c'est un événement mutualisé qui vient
se rajouter à ce que chacun fait comme
événement comme action qu'il propose
dans le cadre de s'accorder particulière
et là l'idée c'est de créer petit à
petit un certain nombre d'événements où
toutes les écoles et établissements vont
pouvoir participer ensemble et donc je
trouve ça très riche pour les élèves de
voir qu'il ya des gens de partout qui
sont là pour les leur permettre de céder
de les aider dans leur orientation
le dispositif deux cordées de la
réussite c'est un dispositif national
qui a pour objectif de favoriser l'accès
à l'enseignement supérieur des jeunes
issus de milieux modestes et quartiers
prioritaires c'est-à-dire politique de
la ville est en fête
il s'agit en fait de tutorat étudiants
vers des collégiens et des lycéens de
ces quartiers prioritaires
sous forme d'ateliers à l'heure
d'ouverture
culturel et scientifique de méthodologie
de travail sur l'orientation et les
métiers etc
un des objectifs c'est justement de
facilité en fait le suivi de ces jeunes
puisque l'intérêt comme ses devoirs sur
un an de tutorat en fait comment ils
vont évoluer et si vraiment il va y
avoir un accès aux études supérieures et
du coup on verra dans un an
donc on espère vous revoir dans un an
pour vous raconter l'évolution de ceux
de ce projet et il faut savoir quand
même que le lancement s'est fait avec
l'ami la secrétaire d'état à la ville
qui madame geoffroy et qui donc soutient
ce projet de manière moins importante
[Musique]